[Musique]
allo maicon c'est vrai bonsoir emmanuel
merci d'être là avec nous on voulait pas
vous déranger certains prix non c'est
matthieu delormeau en fait qui vous aime
beaucoup
alors on a vu manuel valls il ya ça
quelques années on avait essayé d'avoir
françois hollande
ben voilà on a eu pas mal de gens c'est
vrai qu'on est jean luc mélenchon aussi
qui est venu ici et mathieu voilà vous
êtes son idole absolue
je sais que vous êtes en pleine campagne
si vous avez fait votre meeting dimanche
à lyon qui errent vous avait démenti des
choses voilà tout ça la voilà donc
mathieu ont parlé de ça on parlait de ce
démenti est matthieu delormeau voulais
vous parler ce que vous connaissez
matthieu delormeau emmanuel macron alors
excusez moi je ne regarde pas l'émission
mais mon entourage me dit que vous avez
perdu les primaires face à le tuer
verdez
c'est vrai à fréquenter les loosers mais
c'est vrai mais bon voilà c'était
c'était serré et un y avait soixante dix
30 bat mathieu à l'isi parlez-lui bas
bonsoir emmanuel suffrages
ce que je peux vous appeler manuel non
mais manuel c'est pas que je vous aime
énormément je voulais vous dire que
vraiment vous avez moderniser la
politique vous vous êtes vous êtes beau
vous êtes très talentueux vous êtes
notre nouveau vinadie politique est-ce
qu'il est apolitique et à d'autres
nouveaux kennedy je me verrais schmid
est bonne on en avait parlé
[Applaudissements]
mais à l'époque de la personne voilà je
me proposais sens de vente et de
peut-être ne souhaite pas on ne vous
souhaite pas la même fin à neuf mois je
me proposais sans me vanter peut-être
d'être la nouvelle jackie voilà annuel
des gains ils veulent des caveaux du
tout non mais vraiment pas du tout géré
en vue de respect pour vous c'est vrai
beaucoup constat donc je propose est
peut être qu'on prenne un verre dans
dans un hôtel parisien peut-être suite
votre choix commence par un bistrot vous
viendriez avec vos gardes du corps je
viendrai avec les miens c'est donc si
vous avez alors pardon messieurs de
l'homme
oui je suis comme la dernière canicule
moi aussi c'est les vieilles que je
dépanne en premier et je vais vous dire
l'hyper ekoga
[Applaudissements]
marcotte a été fait parce qu'il crie
comme emmanuel a bien sûr emmanuel alors
là on va d'ailleurs mon marquant au
thème forte a été formidable merci merci
c'est la deuxième fois que m
[Applaudissements]